bonjour à toutes et à tous ici arguant
que j'espère que vous allez bien on se
retrouve pour une petite vidéo nous
allons parler de ant man 2 et où je vous
je vais vous exprimer mon avis sur le
film
alors on va faire une partie sans spoil
pour commencer et une partie avec spoilé
justement quelques suppositions par la
suite donc bien évidemment on va
commencer par le sang spoil bah alors du
coup sans spoil en fait
c'est tout bête mais entre man 2 c'est
l'équivalent du 1er mai sans la
découverte
en fait c'est du othman voilà y'a des
blaye c'est tout c'est plutôt pas mal
plutôt drôle ça finisse à se regarder ça
fait un peu c'est un simple ça fait
simple film d'action et puis un petit
marvel en plus quoi et c'est donc c'est
plutôt cool ouais en fait je sais pas
vraiment quoi dire parce que voilà c'est
pas non plus un grand film et c'est un
bon marvel ça reste un marvel et puis
ouais ça reste ça se laisse regarder
quoi c'est bien
et puis je n'en attendais pas grand
chose spécialement et puis au final tout
ce que j'avais prédit est arrivé dans le
film fait donc pour rester dans le sens
spoil en gros dans le synopsis scott est
brouillé avec hank et hop parce que
justement à cause de civil war et où il
a fait le con en voulons aider captain
america contre la justice et du coup il
se retrouve enfermé chez lui
ba sous surveillance policière il a plus
le droit de sortir chez lui et bien
évidemment il ya des événements qui vont
se passer et puis il va y avoir le
personnage du fantôme qui va être le
méchant du film puis voilà le méchant
est pas un méchant incroyable mais reste
tout de même assez sympathique normal on
va dire la relation entre man et la
guêpe est encore beaucoup plus
appréciable qu'avant ils deviennent de
plus en plus proche
et surtout on en apprend énormément sur
le champ quantique la dimension
quantique
voilà j'ai pas grand chose à dire
c'était un bon film mais c'était pas un
film d'exception
voilà c'était un antoine mais sans la
découverte en fait
bon du coup passons la partie spoil où
il ya quand même quelques petits trucs à
dire l'histoire autour de janet van dyne
était plutôt prévisible c'était assez
évident qu'ils allaient retourner qui
est dans le champ quantique pour aller
la chercher
je pensais que ça se serait fait plutôt
quand même mais en même temps c'est vrai
que c'était une mission plutôt capitale
et voilà c'est j'ai pas grand chose à
dire là dessus mais je pensais que ce
serait arrivé un petit peu plus tôt
alors la méchante du nom de havas
c'est voilà c'est pas une incroyable
méchante voilà on sait juste que elle
est une conséquence on va dire elle a
subi les conséquences
deux camps pratiquent la dimension
quantique en fait ça modifie les
cellules etc
et du coup elle n'a ne possède pas
encore stabilisés et du coup elle en
souffre du coup cela nous montre les
conséquences de la dimension quantique
est ce que ça peut apporter
ouais serre moi en fait c'est juste pour
ajouter parce que j'ai oublié de dire
quand je verrai corps la vidéo en fait
ce que j'aime bien dans le méchant de
batman 2 même s'il n'est pas incroyable
c'est que en fait elle est méchante
parce qu'elle souffre en fait est que
n'importe quel être humain qui souffrent
et beaucoup plus dangereux et peut faire
le mal autour de lui juste parce qu'il
souffre en fait et c'est pour ça que
j'aime ce que j'ai bien aimé ce méchant
voilà c'est tout du coup il retrouve
janet janet a des pouvoirs voilà elle
est une sorte de piles quantique on va
dire elle possède voilà de l'énergie
quantique en elle qui lui donne des
pouvoirs qui permettent de guérir
availles du coup
modifier les cellules sait pas trop
comment expliquer je me demande si
j'aime vraiment bien compris la chose en
tout cas janet a maintenant des pouvoirs
ce n'est plus une simple guerre voilà
des gros pouvoir qui ont mûri pendant 30
ans dans la zone quantique
elle n'est plus la même personne et au
ras du cou certainement un rôle à jouer
dans le futur de marvel vous pouvez
effacer tout ce qui est des comics et
c'est parce que rappelez vous que le mc
une s'inspire que très peu des comics
issos bien seulement du squelette et
remodèle le tout et vous comme il est
dit dans le film la dimension quantique
est un petit peu le futur de la saga et
le futur du monde de marvel du
dimensionné plusieurs fois dans le film
et on a le cas avec le retour de djanet
vie tout le film en fait tout le film et
au final je suis plutôt content parce
que j'ai l'impression que c'est
exactement comme je le disais en fait et
surtout par rapport à la dernière vidéo
théorique j'ai fait précédemment parce
que du coup je disais que doctor strange
alors beaucoup ont dit mais oui docteur
strange est mort etc mais intéressé ou
un petit peu genre c'est évident en fait
que tous les héros vont revenir à l'air
sinon c'est la fin du mc eu et voilà on
arrête la saga c'est évident qu'ils vont
tous revenir
dr strange apparemment chercherait un
showman pour maîtriser la dimension
quantique pour abuja 4
et justement entre man reste bloqué dans
la dimension quantique
suite au claquement de doigts de cannes
de thanos pardon qui fit disparaître la
guêpe
janet et hank les trois voilà du coup il
se retrouve tout seul dans la dimension
quantique
ce qui est dingue et là du coup j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi fin là je viens de
sortir du ciné ya genre 30 minutes mais
je réfléchis beaucoup et je pense qu'à
une grosse théorie à faire là dessus
parce que du coup si antoine est dans la
zone quantique normalement avengers 4
est censé se dérouler quelques années
après ventures iii au moment où il tombe
dans la zone quantique
il est au moment de la fin de avengers
droit une fille d'ivoire et du coup il
va y rester quelques années ça veut dire
dans cette dimension quantique
il va pouvoir du coup mieux
l'appréhender et du coup certainement
comme janet est modifié évolué et du
coup antoine posséderait de véritable
pouvoir dans le futur de marvel est
justement comme je disais c'est bon
c'est un peu bad ass un peu bâtard ce
que je veux dire mais c'est à dire la
sélection naturelle majeure
là on va arriver à la phase 4 et ça va
être une phase où les ennemis sont voit
de plus en plus puissants voilà on avait
pu sur la simple terre avec il ya
seulement un voleur 10 des ailes comme
dans spider man et qu'il faut
appréhender la n'en parle de thanos on
parle de dors maman on parle de gros
ennemis et là du coup les héros vont
devoir se sortir les doigts du cul et
possédez de véritables pouvoirs donc
évidemment on a tort qu est surpuissant
qui a même évolué et à ta docteur
strange et tout mais bon entre man voilà
à quoi c'est entre man et là du coup le
fait qu'il est dans cette dimension
quantique
il aura certainement du coup de gros
pouvoir dans avengers 4 des pouvoirs un
petit peu comme comme ceux de djanet où
il va pouvoir maîtriser le champ
quantique être une pile un petit peu
d'énergie quantique pouvoir modifier des
cellules certainement il faut que je me
renseigne plus sur ce pouvoir et du coup
dr strange qui cherchera par hamon
antoine othman serait un pro de la
dimension quantique du coup nous avons
une chance 4 il en ressortirait
certainement je pense grâce à strange je
pense je pense pas que les héros
reviennent avant quand man n'est
intervenue je pense que ce sera
certainement grâce à dr strange
enfin bref je m'attendais pas du tout
cette scène post-générique je savais que
la guêpe et tout allait disparaître mais
je pensais pas que ça allait être
vendons 40 man soit dans la zone
quantique vers ses membres ce
qu'elle-même des tartines grade dans la
zone quantique et c'est justement sur de
petit animal ou
qui est capable de résister à tous en
fait aux plus grandes chaleurs comme en
plus grande
la guerre froide heures aux temps
glacial on va dire ya de quoi faire ça
fuse ça fuse là dedans bref j'ai pas
trop quoi dire en fait de plus sur le
film en fait seulement qu' il apporte
certainement des petites réponses
avengers 4 justement de façon il est
sorti après avengers 4 donc c'est déjà
il ya une petite réponse est la réponse
allait sous nos yeux c'est le chant
quantique antoine enfermés dans le
champs quantique c'est ça va être un
élément clé ça la deuxième scène
post-générique un petit peu troll avec
la fourmi histoire juste de nous faire
attendre à ce qu on sait tous qu'il faut
rester jusqu'à la fin pour voir la scène
post générique du coup entre man élaguer
brûlerie turn mais un petit point
d'interrogation qui m'a assez intrigué
mais non de façon intime hans et moi
souffrons tous revenir et toute façon c
est un élément clé antoine c'est un
élément clé bref je vois pas trop quoi
vous dire de plus là dessus
je réfléchis à si je fais une petite
théorie sur tout ça du coup sur le fait
que ant man va avoir de nouveaux
pouvoirs et va être un élément clé et
surtout voilà il va être enfermé
quelques années dans la dimension
quantique en fait donc il va y avoir des
choses qui vont se passer donc écouter
cet argot rock
je remercie je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo et puis on se retrouve
très prochainement pour une nouvelle
voie là allait céder cups et les keufs
et des fouilles à défoncer les keufs car
tout le monde que l'avionneur soit avec
vous à l'aisselle
[Musique]